I can't even escape.
How
can I scale it all?
Go Fuck.
I just need to get to that point where I
need to get past that fluctuating point
and just go down and start seeing all
these fucking abs that I have under
there.
You know what I'm saying?
I have like 32 ab muscles that I could
possibly see.
Anybody that's overweight wants to have
a fucking six pack before they die.
The fact.
What'd you have?
A chip,
which with the chip,
which it's a fucking to toll house
cookies with ice cream in between.
That sounds awesome.
It was good and it was melted and I
still eat it so it's fucking disgusting.
It's piglets shit.
Shit.
Not a squirrel in my house.
One time in the war and then eventually
the motherfucker eight through the wall.
One day I was laying on the couch and I
just suddenly opened my eyes and look up
and he's just fucking looking at me.
We make eye contact and it's like,
it's a fucking.
It's a standoff and see that movie
Congo.
It's kind of silly.
It was that.
It was terrible.
But the guy with the accent,
you know the one that is always in all
those movies,
the Weirdo.
Which guys?
A fucking weird guy.
He's given that I'm a rat because
stupid.
It is to.
Yeah,
right.
It's an idiot.
I like Russia was there last year.
They breed some hard fucking people.
Some fucking jasmine that Joseph
[inaudible] defined at seven months.
He's me.
Seven months,
not 70 days.
That's a premature child.
Chris Christie didn't want to be
president.
No Way.
No fucking way.
No fucking scumbag.
Is He?
How dare you?
I'm not really sure.
This is what I hear.
I don't really know politics.
Why is he shining?
I don't understand.
Is it the Internet age?
Is that the social media age?
Just making this guy into this figure.
Almost like the Jordan face.
The Jordan,
the meme.
It's like an iconic thing.
Do you know about to pull up the Jordan?
Donald trump is becoming the fucking
Jordan face man.
The crying Jordan Pfe fuck up.
You get the crying Jordan face.
Yeah,
he is.
He's a sick fuck.
He says anything you'd like also 100
percent.
He has one of the littlest dicks in the
world.
There's no doubt about that.
I can't believe what I'm hearing.
You could just tell how he's talking,
but that's the thing.
If he has one,
he fucking bought it.
It was one of those where you have to
fucking pump.
You're nuts.
True,
true,
true trips like a Turkey.
Basically you pump your dick up.